brian windhorst here on the rich eisen
show how are you brian
hi rich
let's start with this are you surprised
by the nets telling kyrie we won't even
play you on the road you surprised about
that one
no they pretty much moved in that
direction last week so to give you a
brief timeline
the the rule was passed the law was
passed by the
mayor of new york bill de blasio
they knew there was a problem and by the
way from what i understand there was a
handful of players on the knicks and
nets who were unvaccinated when this law
came down in august and everybody knew
this was a problem they worked on it for
weeks every other player for the knicks
are next got vaccinated by
the opening of training camp except for
kyrie
kyrie said and everybody said it's not
going to be a problem don't worry about
it actually kyrie said
privacy
they go out to san diego uh so kyrie's
able to do training camp they have a
meeting at josiah their their
billionaire owner's home in la jolla
josiah is very publicly pro-vaccine
um he had kyrie in his house i'm sure
the message was sent kyrie came back to
new york and did not get vaccinated
and so then they they first said kyrie
we're not going to
prove our practices you can't practice
with us kyrie still did not get
vaccinated then they said kyrie we don't
think
that we're going to necessarily be able
to play you in a away game
uh even even though that
that's allowed unless you get backstage
kyrie still didn't get vaccinated and
after three bites at the apple kyrie
irving struck out and they said we're
moving on without you now he obviously
could end this
today tomorrow whenever he only needs to
get one shot to satisfy the rule but it
is an untenable situation to play in the
nba or you can't have a guy
uh you know play with you on a regular
basis especially when you have long
homestand the
second week of the season the nets start
a six game home stand how are you not
gonna play with somebody for six games
and then bring him back to the seventh
and so they just pulled the plug on it
so do we know
and i'm gonna ask you a question about
you knowing what's in kyrie's mind
do we know if it is something that he
has legitimately researched and feels
that the vaccine is dangerous for him or
there is some sort of belief system that
it's
against that belief system or is it now
just i'm not going to let anybody tell
me what to do i've got enough money or
i've got enough pride i'm a prideful man
nobody's telling me what to do in this
world what is it do we know i'm sure
that some of it i i mean i don't i won't
speak recovery but i will say this
there's a point in kyrie's career where
he he broke his kneecap
and he had surgery where they put some
hardware into his knee uh some screws i
believe and those screws later became
infected and he had to have surgery to
take him out and he got this infection i
don't remember the exact type of
infection i don't want to mistake but he
ended up having to get treated with this
very serious infection for a long time
and so after somebody would go through
something like that i would understand
that you would raise your level of
concern and awareness of what goes into
your body so i definitely agree that
kyrie probably has a different worldview
than the average person on the street
having said that he understands
that if he doesn't get vaccinated he
can't play we've made crystal clear to
him
hundreds of other nba players were
presented with the same situation all
the other players in new york
uh were presented with the same
situation they said i have to do this to
play for my team
if you look at this at this next roster
[ __ ]
it's a whole bunch of veteran guys
who came there to win a championship
obviously durant and harden but a bunch
of guys who gave up money elsewhere to
come play there guys in their 30s this
is their last chance paul millsap
lamarcus aldridge blake griffin james
johnson
i could go on and they're there and
they're like we're going to try to do
this mission and so
they all got vaccinated some of them
probably didn't want you but they got
vaccinated and so kyrie on this front
has little credibility in that locker
room and while sean marx gave a press
conference today
and he stopped short of saying that
kevin durant approved this or signed off
on it he basically said
you can ask kevin his thoughts on it
myself
i have little doubt that they didn't
have kevin durant's um thumbs up
gratifying this um even if they're not
gonna frame it that way because durant
knows he had to make this um a decision
as well
so where do things stand i mean do
we wait for a kyrie statement or is
there is there a point where he will be
made available or the nets just uh cut
ties with him and thus can't make him
available like literally what is the
next step on this sort of thing play
basketball and then revisit it or or
he's going to cvs right now i mean like
what you know what i mean like what what
happens here
he has two choices really he can't well
i guess he's got three choices
but i mean two viable choices
the first choice is to wait for the
situation and the pandemic to improve
and perhaps this law in new york is
um you know nullified released
um
who knows um you know there is a mayoral
election coming up i believe in november
there will be a new mayor
the delta variance numbers are going
down knock on wood but who knows
if the idea is going to change but i
mean in theory he could wait it out
or two he could
you know i don't want to say eat crow
because that sounds like he's some sort
of
you know bad thing but he'd have to get
the shot i guess he could also
three just retire
you know but i don't think that's viable
but i will say this
when he says no to this he's not just
saying no
to playing on this championship team
he's not just saying no
to half of his salary because he will
not get paid half of his salary he'll
still get paid for the away games even
though they're choosing to make him
inactive but the nets were prepared to
give him a 160 million dollar
contract extension this off-season this
is not i'm telling you based on sources
the general manager sean marks when they
signed durant to a contract extension
said in august we hope to have kyrie
signed by the start of camp obviously
he's not getting that contract extension
right now
i don't know if he'll ever get it and
even if he was trained to another team
based on his decision making and his
focus
he's making a decision that he probably
is never going to get that at least for
the time being
he's put a lot on the line especially
financially and also competing for this
championship for to defend the way he
feels espn's brian windhorst here on the
rich eisen show um and this was uh
breaking news earlier tuesday monday
night i'll share a text exchange gents
that i had with brian here with brian on
the phone when he was booked i said
looking forward to solving the ben
simmons problem with you on air you
responded that will take 30 seconds
um
okay
so
i'll give you the 30 seconds take more
if you'd like brian have you ever played
poker you know you know the game of
poker i do very well
yeah okay
ben simmons
made a bluff and then and the 76ers
called it
and then folded
that's basically it huh he folded and uh
the game's not over the hand is over
though
all right so we've moved the button uh
now who's the dealer is that uh is that
make daryl moore is the dealer in this
poker game now because does that mean
that simmons is
uh
back in the sixers fold and thus they
can give off the impression to the
league that they're happy sticking with
him and now that makes him uh a
more uh i guess dollar on the dollar
rather than cents on the dollar for a
trade like literally what happens now do
you think well
now let's see
how the next hand plays
how is ben going to play this next hand
is he gonna play it
the jimmy butler way where jimmy butler
wanted to be traded didn't get traded so
he came into training camp and was an
a-hole
took the third team and embarrassed his
uh other starters and basically serve
notice and if you don't trade me i want
to continue to mentally dominate you
i don't see that in ben's repertoire but
maybe he'll switch up his play
will he
report and plays full-bore basketball
and show his all-nba form and
you know lift his trade value will he
claim injury or maybe he has a real
injury but that is an option here you
know the
this actually turned into something
you're familiar with uh rich in fact i
called mike cannonbaum last week
to get guidance on how
football holdouts operate because this
turned into a football holdout
um
the you know in the nfl
uh players signing bonuses are held in
escrow
which i guess is a relic of back in the
days when
the players weren't sure that the teams
actually had the money
and if you wanted to put my money that
i'm supposed to get in in a year in
escrow you gotta if i want to make sure
i'm gonna get it so as a result when a
player is holding out which usually is a
player who has a signing bonus a high
level player
and he gets fined they just pull the
money right out of that escrow account
that the team can actually physically
put it in its pocket well ben simmons
was planning on
the sixers following his contract which
is pay me a quarter of my salary on july
1st they did 8 million bucks pay me the
second quarter of my salary on october
1st which would have been 8 million
bucks and his first actual paycheck but
he could have been fined in wouldn't
have been until november 15th so they
could find him
eight billion dollars between now and
november 15th but as long as it was
resolved on november 15th
he could negotiate his way out of it
that's the way the nfl used to do it set
out all of training camp but you get
your contract done part as part of your
new deal it gives you back to find money
but the nfl caught on to this and they
started they changed the rule so that if
once you were fined you could never get
the money back
and that potentially what the 76ers did
without getting clearance to do it
instead of giving ben simmons the money
that he was supposed to get on october
1st they put in an escrow account
this is something that's never been done
before
in the nba and i would all i don't know
for sure but i would bet it was done as
they looked at how the nfl handles hold
out players and so with every time that
ben simmons didn't show for a practice
or a game or whatever they pulled money
out of that escrow account and so
instead of him having half of his salary
in his pocket and then we'll figure it
out by november 15th
now all of a sudden he only had a
quarter of his salary in his pocket and
every single day he was watching money
come on out of that escrow account and
he's reported and i'd say that the 76ers
won that round and so let's now see
will he do what nfl players do when he
pushed back as a result nfl players like
tj watt for example
they didn't hold out they held in report
and then basically don't play
will after seeing this after seeing the
sixers act like an nfl team will ben
simmons african nfl player and hold in
that is the next round of this poker
match we're going to watch or where
he just gets traded i mean what why why
why hasn't this uh code redman ordered
like why why why is he still on this
team i mean
honestly you got you got game one friday
october 22nd in philadelphia that's
their first home game he'll be savaged
once he
steps on that court we all know it the
whole the whole world knows it and
and whether you know kid deserves it or
not you know i mean how how is this
attainable at all
moving forward brian
right well because the sixers don't like
what they are gonna get are being
offered right now and
again let's go back to the poker analogy
the hands of daryl mori keeps getting
dealt he doesn't like so he's throwing
him away
he's throwing them away and he's saying
i'm just gonna wait i'm gonna wait
for that team that was uh that general
manager who knows he's gonna make the
playoffs or lose his job for his team to
get off to a 500 starts he starts to
seize an 8-8 or something i'm gonna wait
for that team that has a major injury
and needs a um
needs a uh needs a major trade or i'm
gonna wait for another star player who i
may want
to get angry with his team and demand a
trade
and and uh so really daryl moore is just
kicking the can down the road he doesn't
like what his trade options are now
he's really it's not really his
prerogative at this point
to
make sure ben is is uh is happy with the
fans um
he you know he i think he's just waiting
for the situation to improve so his
trade options options improve and it's
kind of an important maneuver because if
you look at the sixers and where they
are as an organization they're in joel
indeed's prime
they built a decade to get this team
they were the number one seed in the
eastern conference last year before you
know indeed got hurt and simmons you
know went down the side of his leg in
the middle of the playoff series this is
not a time to take a step back and so he
doesn't feel he can make a trade it is a
trade that what we call a four quarters
trade
you take the dollar that has been
simmons and you trade them for four
quarters because in the nba four corners
doesn't make a dollar you wait where you
can trade a dollar for a dollar now does
that work
maybe not but he knows it's not going to
work today the situation could change by
november 20th or december 15th
last one for you brian windhorst that
october 22nd home opener for the sixers
is against the
brooklyn nets what about daryl taking
sean marks aside and saying yeah
you know
philadelphia doesn't require vaccinated
players to play indoors
and you know we uh we think ben simmons
would look pretty good over there let's
swap our problems for each other
what do you think of that one well two
things i'm going to say about that one
we don't know for sure that ben simmons
is vaccinated
um we shouldn't assume that okay um but
we also and a big factor here is that
kyrie
uh
what he has what he report after a trade
number one number two he has one year
left on his contract he can opt out
after next season
now at this point i think he would be
crazy
to opt out but if you're philadelphia
you're not going to make that type of
trade with a guy who you may be renting
for a year so while i agree on paper
it makes all the sense of the world the
next
badly need perimeter defense it would be
terrific to get ben simmons he wouldn't
need the ball
they could let james harden handle it he
could play off of it it would be perfect
kyrie can come in kyrie actually has a
good relationship with joel embiid way
way better it impedes relationship with
ben simmons and the way they could play
off each other would be terrific
it makes all the sense in the world but
there's so much else
at hand
that would be difficult and actually
negotiating the trade the actual
mechanics of the trade that i think it's
hard to necessarily see at least right
now and especially if philadelphia mayor
jim kenny suddenly day after the trade
says guess what we have a vaccination
mandate to play inside in philadelphia
now and then that would blow that up too
i mean this is
this is crazy brian i mean what a crazy
world we're living in right now and the
nba is right around the corner i
appreciate your two cents as always
thank you thank you have a good day you
bet drive safely that's brian windhorst
always makes us smarter always makes us
think right here on the rich eisen show
from the worldwide leader in sports hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here